I just want to start off this video by
saying I am deeply deeply sorry I've
been deceiving you guys for the last two
years
um you all think I live in this nice
place with this nice brick fireplace
but
this room is actually a total mess
so when we moved in here we had so many
plans for this room we were gonna use it
for hanging out for watching TV for
reading but then I started my YouTube
channel and it just kind of became a
filming room and I just totally
neglected it pretty badly and it's been
being used for just storage pretty much
so now we're finally taking the step to
make this place a little bit nicer and
so today I want to show you my thought
process for transforming this place into
a more livable and functional Space by
just using my iPad a portion of this
video is sponsored by Wayfair more on
their Awesome YouTube series later in
this video as I've mentioned in some of
my other videos my design workflow has
changed completely since I got my iPad I
used a combination of procreate and more
folio for most of my design work and if
you want you you can check out some of
the brushes and backgrounds that I use
on a daily basis in the link in the
description so I have gone ahead and
cleaned up the room a little bit just so
that I can show you around and so I do
have a fairly interesting set of
constraints in this room so the filming
room is in the basement so first of all
it's got a pretty low ceiling height
it's about eight feet which is about uh
2.4 meters for the rest of the world
and I have this very narrow strip window
and very little daylight which is
actually perfect for filming
over here I have my filming setup which
is constantly constantly a mess
um I've got my camera and my equipment
my lenses my cables all on this Shelf
and I have my camera right in the center
and sometimes Raph will sit here and
help me and typically I'll have like a
bunch of lights around here and
um I'm like sitting here with my laptop
and my notes and I do like to keep the
setup fairly permanent because it just
removes a lot of the friction out of
filming and if any of you guys are
interested in starting YouTube channels
I feel like that's one of the easiest
things that you can do to keep your
videos consistent just to have like a
permanent setup and over here I have the
couch right now and I have this really
ugly bulkhead sticking down and it
brings down the ceiling to about six
foot eight I think that's about two
meters
and it is in the same datum as the top
of this window so because this room
feels very like fragmented right now I'm
gonna try to use this datum to try to
create a little bit of order in the
space
and of course over here I have my
filming backdrop and I am kind of
considering whitewashing this
I don't know I'm getting a little bit
sick of this red fireplace are you guys
getting a little bit sick of it I'm
getting a little bit sick of it so we'll
see but even when I'm not filming it is
kind of the Hearth of this room it's the
place where your eyes are naturally
drawn to when you enter the room and
because the space is quite small with a
fairly low ceiling height I want to
visually extend the length of this room
a little bit and when I first moved in
here that was the intent of these low
horizontal shelves we just cut up some
wooden panels and set them on these
concrete blocks but over time we
realized that they're great for
displaying things but they're not very
functional and the space just got really
messy really fast so before I had my
iPad I would have probably drawn up an
actual true elevation and started
sketching on that but these days I find
it the easiest to just like take a photo
and start sketching on top of that this
way I can really just quickly sketch out
some ideas and see which ones I want to
develop further whether it's in a 3D
model or in a render and it's a really
fast way for me to try out different
options and as I'm doing this I am
simultaneously going on Pinterest and
picking out some inspiration images for
the room because that's I think one of
the most fun parts of an interior design
project I think my style preference is
somewhere between mid-century modern
Scandinavian but I also love the rough
natural textures of that Mediterranean
or the Japanese wabi-sabi look but as I
was finding these images I kept seeing
the term Japan the in Japan the in Japan
D and I discover that there is a very
specific style that's the perfect
combination of all of these and actually
I learned this through wayfarer's
YouTube channel I knew Wayfair as a
website where you can buy affordable
Chic looking furniture but I never knew
that they had an educational YouTube
channel they have a new series called a
style is born where they discuss how and
why certain Styles came to be I love how
they break down the history of that
style from the social and economic
conditions and why it's making a
comeback and I think when you understand
the context behind something you can
appreciate it a lot more Beyond just the
Aesthetics of it it can also help you
understand why you're drawn to that
specific chair or table or vase anyways
I would highly recommend you check out
their episode on japandy it's really
well produced it's really well
researched and it's really fun to watch
so yeah go subscribe to their channel
it's full of really great content I'll
include the link in the description so
I'm gonna put this photo on as my base
layer and the first thing that I do is
I'm going to set up the grids and I'm
gonna use this to set up my bass lines
and then I adjust the photo to have
straight horizontals and verticals as
much as possible without going into
Photoshop and fixing up the photo
[Music]
and then I'll put on the perspective
grid and I'm just going to leave this on
throughout the duration of this process
try to align the perspective lines as
best as you can and create another layer
on top so this layer is going to be your
base outline your walls and your doors
or your windows and basically elements
that are already in the space once you
do this you're going to have some lines
that naturally come out and I'm using
that as my starting point for the design
we've got this strip window and this
bulkhead that are kind of more or less
on the same level and we also have this
wall that jogs in a couple of inches and
because this room has a lot of
fragmented elements I want to use this
as a datum to try to bring some order
into the space before I start sketching
I draw out a very rough plan of the
options I want to look at I'm going to
need about eight boxes those are calyx
boxes of storage which probably means I
should get about 12 to 16 because uh you
know I want to be realistic I think a
good rule of thumb for life is to
account for double the amount of storage
that you think you're gonna need so I
want to explore an option where I have a
large storage unit that goes up to this
wall Jog and an option where I have low
storage units broken up into two
sections and maybe I'll do some
iterations off of that I'll have my desk
get my camera set up right here and
sometimes my partner sits right next to
the camera to help me film and so if you
have these non-negotiable constraints
like this you can just put them right
into to the base drawing
so this large storage unit I'd align it
to our datum and maybe this corner can
be its own thing so what I'm doing here
with the curtains is I'm pulling it just
past my window all the way to the end of
the wall so it looks like the window
continues all the way through and I'm
starting the curtain right from the
ceiling all the way to the floor so it
adds some height to the space but as you
can see already I think the storage unit
is a little bit big for the space
especially because we've got this very
low ceiling height and it's already
starting to feel a little bit
overwhelming so we can try something a
little bit smaller but that just doesn't
really work with any of the grids so it
just looks a little bit awkward in the
space I think a lower storage works a
lot better with the proportions of this
particular space maybe with a wall shelf
along the stadium line and you can see
how I've done something really similar
with my home office which is also really
fragmented like there's a window that's
off the center there's this bulkhead and
there's doors and kind of awkward places
but in this case I was able to create a
continuous perimeter with the shelving
so I decided to put lights to up like
the ceiling and give the illusion of a
taller space but with this room I'm not
going to be able to continue this line
across the room so I'm not going to be
uplighting this and instead I'm probably
going to use it for storing books or my
models or anything that I don't reach on
a very regular basis so proportionally I
think these smaller shelves work a lot
better so I like how this option is
creating its own little Zone and I'll
probably put in like an area rug just to
emphasize this filming Zone by the way
I'm just drawing this furniture in as
placeholders but I am going to go
through the process of selecting the
furniture later but probably I'm going
to go with Ikea shelving anyways because
it's the most cost effective and I don't
want to spend a ton of money on the
space can't I'm gonna try flipping the
TV and the couch so that when you walk
in you see the couch instead of the TV I
kind of like this Arrangement because it
creates more of an enclosure and I might
end up changing it like this so I kind
of go back and forth between these
different elevations just to make sure
that the space feels coherent as a whole
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
once I've got this design to the level I
want I modeled this into SketchUp with
some generic Furniture blocks just to
get a more accurate sense of scale so as
you can see I've created a little bit
more order into the space by creating
some continuous lines with these shelves
and by reinforcing symmetry with the
artwork I'm also trying to make the
space feel a little bit more open by
using low Furniture elements and a
scones around eye level to bring down
the sight line and I've added some tall
artworks and Tall curtains to elongate
the space a little bit I'm also creating
two zones with the shelving and the area
rugs in the next phase I'm going to go
through the process of developing a mood
board and a material palette and at that
point I'm also going to print out the
perspectives from the SketchUp model to
play around with the materials so that I
know exactly what pieces I should buy
before going to the store if you're
interested in this procreate brush pack
I have everything from pens to markers
to brushes as well as to people
Silhouettes I'm going to leave that in
the description if you have any
questions on anything that I went
through today just let me know down in
the comments and if you like this video
please give me a thumbs up and stay
tuned for the rest of the renovation
it's going to be very exciting and I
will see you in the next video
foreign